Speaker 1: I have absolutely brutal video for
you. Tennessee Republican governor Bill Lee
is going hard anti drag and anti-trans and was
confronted with pictures of himself dressed in
drag years ago. This is just unbelievable. Let's
go right to the video first and then I will tell
you all of the details. But this is oof, this
this is something take a look at this bill now.
Speaker 2: The transgender
bill, children sent into therapy
that's on your desk. A drag bill heads back to
the center for a quick a minute for you to desk.
Speaker 3: Comfortable sign those tax
legislation? Yeah. Expects to send
over, drive and drag in 1977. What a ridiculous,
ridiculous question that is. Conflating something
like that to sexualized intersex.
Speaker 1: Realized.
Speaker 3: Tainment in front of children, which is
a very serious subject. Andy Which got this you,
Andy. I just wondering if you're aware
of any specific cases or distances that
this bill limits. Are you aware of
specifics in terms of this problem?
I think that the concern is what's right
there in that class and that building.
Children that are potentially exposed to
sexualized entertainment, to obscenity.
Speaker 1: And obscenity, commanded.
Speaker 3: To make sure that they're not.
I think that's something that should happen
and to see them live because of this bill.
Speaker 2: Would you be okay with proceeding
on things like the drag Queens comedies? This
is you. This is you at a high school governor.
This right here. Is you at a high school? Yeah.
Is it only illegal when gay people don't go? Have
you talked to your sister about the bill going?
Speaker 1: All right. So everything about this
is just wacky. First and foremost, you know,
the idea that there is some predatory nature to
the drag queen story hours or we've already talked
about it. We've we've looked at it extensively.
There is a sort of mishmash happening which
really shouldn't be between the drag queen stuff
and the trans bathroom stuff. And these really
are two separate issues. We interviewed a drag
performer a couple of weeks ago who explained,
like you might be trans and also be a drag
performer. But there really are two separate
things. Let's look at a couple article excuse
me, a couple of articles here. The Daily Beast.
Drag ban in Tennessee. Governor shrugs, shrugs
off old drag pic as a lighthearted tradition
with Billy poised to sign a bill outlawing drag
performances. Imagine that an apparent photo
from his high school yearbook has surfaced. The
other thing that was mentioned in all of this,
by the way, is obscenity that they're concerned
with. Tennessee already has obscenity laws. So if
the concern is obscenity or sexualization
that already is handled by Tennessee law,
and so claiming you need this new law doesn't
actually make any sense. A photo emerged writes
The Daily Beast on Reddit over the weekend
from the Franklin High Yearbook in 77, where
Lee attended, purportedly showing Lee dressed as
a woman, along with the caption Hard luck, Hard
luck woman. But that's different. Lee's office
told The Daily Beast, saying light hearted school
traditions shouldn't be conflated with what the
state is. Banning the bill specifically protect
children from obscene, sexualized entertainment.
And any attempt to conflate the serious issue with
lighthearted school traditions is dishonest and
disrespectful to Tennessee families. When asked
during the press conference if he remembered it,
he didn't deny the photo was of him, but said
it's a ridiculous question. NBC News reporting
Tennessee governor appears to have dressed in
drag an art form he wants to restrict. There
are sort of like three different things here.
As is so often the case with these right wing
clowns, there's the personal hypocrisy. Now,
on the issue of drag. You wouldn't think like,
how does this keep happening? Kerry Lake, a very
dangerous drag queens. Kerry Lake organized,
if I recall correctly, a drag performance in
at minimum, attended it. Billy We're banning drag
because it's sexualized and obscene and this and
that. Oh, he dressed in drag. And actually, the
law already bans obscenity. Okay, So the one
part is the hypocrisy. The second part is, as I
started to mention, the actual thing they say is
the problem with drag isn't really the problem.
But if it were meaning the obscenity or whatever,
a lot of these states already have so-called
anti obscenity laws on the books, so you wouldn't
actually need these bills. And then number three
is what the reporter asked, which is, is there a
single specific example you can cite of what it
is that this bill would stop? And, you know, we
went through this with the trans bathroom stuff,
which is, okay. So it's going to stop men who say
I'm a woman in order to go into the women's room
and spy on young girls and take pictures. And
we already have laws against that. And there
are no examples of that happening from states
that are more progressive when it comes to
the trans bathroom stuff. So it's, again, a
solution in search of a problem to virtue signal.
If you want to learn more about virtue signaling,
we have a clip on the YouTube channel that I did
last week. So nonsense all around. Great to see
Bill Lee confronted. These people are clowns.
These people are virtue signaling. They're
playing into these culture wars and they're
doing it in a horrifyingly authoritarian way